okay so disgusting depraved diabolical
disgrace of a Senator Ted Cruz was
confronted at LAX Airport with a chant
of free the children we have it on video
and I'm here to tell you again this is
okay
I'm okay with this and I know people are
going to write to me and tell me no
David no it's immoral for you to be okay
with this I'm okay with it and I'll tell
you why in a second let's look at the
video first Ted Cruz the recipient of
all sorts of chants and booing Cruz
meanwhile taking pictures with fans in
the midst of the chant it's pretty funny
video
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this has happened to crews before we
covered the incident last year where he
was heckled out of a restaurant in
Washington DC so listen I'm okay with
this I'm against physical violence I'm
against throwing anything at politicians
or whoever including milkshakes that's a
crime you can get arrested for it I'm
against property crimes against the
homes of elected officials that we don't
like this is just speech is it loud it's
sort of loud its group speech it's more
than one person that's true these are
politicians who are doing disgusting
things they're complicit or even
supportive of policies that are ruining
people's lives irrevocably yes it's
uncomfortable to be at an airport and to
have a crowd chanting stuff at you I can
understand that if it can happen at Ted
Cruz it could happen to Bernie or Warren
or me or whoever and it has happened to
Bernie as we've covered before in fact
there was Alex Jones who was heckling
Bernie in that viral video that we
covered but there is not nearly enough
being done to make our elected officials
actually feel uncomfortable for the
policies that they're supporting and
carrying out it's very easy for our
elected officials to be completely
isolated between their security and
their sedan services and their first
class lounges and whatever else it's
very easy to be completely isolated from
the reactions of people beyond what they
read on Twitter this is called
your actions have consequences it feels
so weak when people write to me and say
David it's not okay to heckle
politicians in a public place it's not
respectful they're advocating for
policies that would lead to tens of
millions losing access to health care
they're supporting the interrogation and
the moral caging of children or at least
looking the other way about it they're
debating whether or not children and
cages deserve soap and a toothbrush when
they're held for days on end they're
defending one of the most immoral
corrupt presidents that we have had and
you're saying it's inappropriate to
chant in a public space we need to draw
the line in
reasonable place the line is before we
get to property crime the line is before
we get to setting fire to things the
line is before Street beatings or
whatever else right
chanting in public come on guys this is
not sensible this is not logical I'm
open to having my mind changed but
you've got to make a good argument as to
why I should be against chanting at Ted
Cruz in public quick break give us a
like on Facebook facebook.com slash
David Pakman show we'll be right back
after this today's program brought to
you in part by Blink accom slash Pakman
blinka is a great service that i use all
the time what they do is they take
thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers they condense them into
15-minute audiobooks that you can listen
to and you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink as' I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on blinka they're constantly
adding new books to the platform you
will never run out of fascinating and
critically acclaimed books to enjoy and
our audience can get a 7 day free trial
by going to blink is calm slash Pakman
if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about 5 bucks a
month that's be li NK is t.com /pa k ma
n